what happens when you die
we've talked before and and you're what
you're an atheist
i'm an atheist yes
uh
although it's weird because we were yeah
i'm i'm an atheist but here's
where he i think the everyone goes well
the ultimate atheist test is you know if
you uh witness a miracle or you go you i
think the ultimate atheist test is if
you have a little i have a four and a
half year old daughter so when a when a
pet dies
and your your kid is upset you can't
just tell them that there isn't a doggy
heaven you have to
basically lie and just go oh yo he's up
are you kidding he's on clouds made of
biscuits and it's
no he's fine like you totally have to
bs that not only do i not know what
happens i don't know how to put this
into a will
i absolutely
don't care what happens to my body there
should be a service that just comes to
your house and the minute you die grabs
your body and anything even if someone
wants like a piece of skin for a
notebook cover they can have it i don't
care
just
give give the body to people that'll do
some cool stuff with it and then get a
keg and everyone watch lethal weapon and
i'm fine that
could be my funeral